ce qu'il vous faut pour vous c'est des
films vivant voilà que ça remue que ça
remet tait tusson et du sang voilà en
plus j'aime beaucoup les films de guerre
pourquoi c'est à dire parce que on peut
voir dans ses films comment vécu nos aux
parents quoi et vous allez au cinéma en
banque tout seul avec vos parents peut
toujours en bandoulière enfin au moins
trois quatre camarades ou alors des
vents de troupes pour voir un petit fils
me manque je crois qu'en général la
femme mieux les films dramatiques parce
que elle est toujours quelque peu
émotive et puisse à lui créé quelques
sensations je considère le cinéma comme
une arme
c'est à dire c'est un super moyens qui
doit servir à faire prendre conscience
aux gens de certaines choses et je suis
contraint certains cinémas commercialisé
principaux que le cinéma puisse avoir
une influence sur notre façon de penser
de pays je passe
il faut s'en défende oui le cinéma
qu'est ce que c'est pour vous tous enfin
c'est quelque chose
c'est une fresque une raison de vivre
vous préférez le cinéma sur 350 millions
de places vendues annuellement par le
cinéma français
plus de 175 millions le sont à des moins
de 20 ans c'est pourquoi nous avons cru
bon ce soir de nous pencher sur le
problème des rapports entre le cinéma et
les jeunes
tour à tour à paris en province nous
avons interviewé deux jeunes ouvriers de
jeunes employés des étudiants au travers
des réponses reçues nous avons essayé de
découvrir qu'elle pouvait être le
pouvoir du cinéma
et quel était son importance dans la
formation et l'éducation de ces jeunes
c'est un médecin pédiatre le docteur
cathy le fondateur du ciné club d'angers
l'un des plus importants de france
qui nous dit tout d'abord qu'elle peut
être selon lui l' influence du cinéma
sur la jeunesse docteur pensez vous que
le cinéma puisse avoir une influence sur
les jeunes sans aucun doute de cinéma a
une influence sur les jeunes cette
influence a parfois et souvent été bonne
heureusement d'ailleurs c'est tout à son
honneur mais aussi nous avons
malheureusement d'autres exemples dans
un autre sens opposé et nous avons
insisté même dans la région à
l'organisation d'une bande en
particulier qui s'est créé de toutes
pièces après la projection du film
terrain vague avec un timide à la tête
avec une carte d'immatriculation
obligatoires pour entrer dans cette
bande où les jeunes sont allés jusqu'à
dresser cette carte avec tout un langage
que j'ai pu lire qui m'a absolument
ahuri et à signer cette carte d'une
tache de sang c'était indispensable dans
un cadre réservé des lieux à cela
exactement comme cela se passait dans le
film exactement comme les choses été
racontée dans le film la délinquance
infantile n'a pas une cause dans le
cinéma mais le cinéma peut la favoriser
dans des cas où le jeune n'est pas
parfaitement en équilibre au point de
vue psychologique mais ce que je crois
accentue le cinéma c
dans le sens d'un certaine déformation
au point de vue de l'évolution sexuelle
des jeunes et c'est là peut-être le
cinéma a parfois une influence un petit
peu néfastes et que nous regrettons il
est certain que ceux ci dévient quelque
peu l'éducation sentimentale de base qui
se sont faits entre eux entre garçons et
filles dans la vie courante
parce que le cinéma n'est pas nous
savons bien l'expression la vie courante
c'est une déformation trop souvent de la
réalité paris
entre l'appartement marc et la porte de
clients
pour les jeunes de ces quartiers
populaires le cinéma est avant tout une
évasion c'est que l'on travaille dur
depuis l'âge de 15 ans et le soir quand
on rentre à la maison
dans l'appartement taupe exiguë pour
contenir toute la famille on n'a qu'une
idée repartir et l'on voit au cinéma
n'importe où au hasard histoire de
changer d'air le film pour le choisis
d'après les affiches collées au mur
[Musique]
choisissez le film vous allez voir ce
soir monsieur winch ou vous venez
souvent cinéma russe bon c'est à dire
combien de femmes de près par semaine on
solde ponctuelles tordo fume glocer et
vous vous allez souvent cinéma eu droit
qu'à trois semaines et vous choisissez
les [ __ ] plus à l'est oui dans quel
genre de salé ou d'impôts salle de
quartier le moins possible pourquoi je
sais pas c'est bien
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'est ce que
vous entendez par une salle qui n'est
pas assez bien rock
il faut une sa luxueuse pour brûler ses
marques
et quels champs ne fume pas ferez-vous
je suis mise en scène des noms
d'artistes
et maintenant quel genre de thé vous
allez voir on ça dépend un peu amour
mais pas seulement
quand le monde ce qu'il vous faut pour
vous c'est des films vivant voilà que
formule que ça remet tait tout son et du
sang voilà en plus et qu'est ce qu'est
ce qui est important pour vous dans un
film c'est l'histoire c'est le metteur
en scène c'est sans les voeux des
maisons sun qui a dont fut par exemple
c'était moi un film qui vous a plu
un genre de film comme spartacus des
films claude kouassi jolies et fines
nouvelle vague patrie nouvelle phase
le pianiste de rock et films de cow-boys
les films de cow-boys pourquoi si
dynamique et les films sentimentaux vous
aimez ça j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup les
films de gaines pourquoi c'est à dire
parce que on peut voir dans ses films
comment vécu nos eaux par en quoi est-ce
que vous pensez que le cinéma représente
exactement la vie comme elle est oh non
non non je pense pas j'avais vu terrain
vague
et alors vous êtes d'accord avec lui
oui oui c'est la représente exactement
la jeunesse domaine est actuellement
pris vous aimez brigitte bardot au banc
tellement bascule s'en foutent ils
demandent même genre qu'est ce que vous
lui reprochez à brigitte bardot ensuite
ailleurs café troupe d habiller alors à
force la population à non la mer après
ça vous plaît pas les épreuves en sus
s'appelait way un petit peu de temps en
temps la alors tout autre bon le cinéma
beaucoup cette distraction envoya
d'apprendre quelque chose
une distraction unique bonne distraction
oui
vous ne pensez pas que ça peut j'accuse
et un peu
vous préférez le bal au cinéma art et
pourquoi vous préférez le bal au cinéma
en smart mieux au ciné club d'ivry ciné
club populaire dont le nombre
d'adhérents augmente sans cesse
le cinéma prend une toute autre valeur
son rôle est ici de compléter une
culture parfois défaillant depuis
combien de temps avez-vous au ciné-club
saratar ma deuxième année
quel métier faites vous je suis tourneur
outilleur dans un établissement de
fabrication de chemise pour voitures et
vous monsieur depuis combien de temps
des réussi au ciné-club ce fameux google
mauvais deuxième bébé et quels métiers
faites vous originellement je suis
boulanger pâtissier motors travaille
dans le grand magasin un tel âge avez
vous commencé à l'oci mina pour la
première fois tout seul
14 ans et vous y alliez tout seul ou
avec des garçons est tout seul sans la
qu'ils en sont le parrainage de mes
parents autrement nous y allons en bande
avec des gars en diffi garçons et nous
essayons de rencontre des filles aussi
les moeurs logiquement
est ce que le fait d'aller au cinéma en
bande augmenter le plaisir par un film
absolument
au départ ce n'était pas le plaisir de
les voir un film c'était surtout le
plaisir de rencontrer les amis et les
caméras bhl le passé un dimanche après
midi ensemble
est ce que ces discussions que vous avez
aussi nick loeb reste uniquement sur le
plan cinématographique tout ça dépend du
film je vais vous donner un exemple nous
avons au début de la saison come back
africa
c'est un film qui traite un sujet sur le
racisme c'est un film sur lequel on ne
pouvait pas à travers la discussion
discuter seulement des images ou de la
réalisation du film on était obligé
d'aborder les problèmes le problème
social le problème même jusqu'aux
problèmes politiques qui avait amené le
réalisateur justement à faire ce film
qu'est ce que vous attendez du civil
j'attende un reflet réel de de ce qui se
passe tous les jours
lorsqu'on a voulu aborder aussi le
problème de la jeunesse des quartiers
ouvriers
je me rappelle de terrain là qu'on a
donné une idée fausse haussier je crois
de cette jeunesse lorsque à travers ce
groupe da chez l'homme on avait l'air de
vouloir faire croire que les jeunes qui
habite à landskrona chanel avait
tendance à se regrouper pour devenir des
bandes de voyous des banlieues bleues
et moi je crois que c'est faux est ce
qu'il y à des sujets que le cinéma ne
traite pas que vous aimeriez voir sur
votre écran oui par exemple la guerre
d'algérie pourquoi parce que je pense
c'est un problème qui a intéressé toute
la génération et que la censure brimer
n'a pas toléré n'est ce pas ce qui
prouve notablement cette censure et est
abominable dans son esprit même dans son
essence et que un problème qui est
intéressé sept ans n'est ce pas de la
vie dans une française de 24 ans que ce
qui est mon cas aurait dû trouver une
seule comment dirais-je lui une
expression plus large sur les écrans moi
le cinéma ce que ça devrait être surtout
ça devrait être large justement de de
l'ensemble de la population
chacun retrouve à travers les films un
peu de sa ville un peu de ce qu'ils
recherchent
avec une bonne idée vous ne voyez pas
d'un cinéma un moyen d'une possibilité
de vous évader
non absolument pas la vie actuellement
ne permet pas de mme ebadi et moi même
et je considère que ma foi on l'a pas
raison de s'évader
même pour une heure et demie alors que
tant de problèmes restent à régler sur
le terre son peuple s'il je pense pas et
maintenant
rendons nous à en province à angers
si les jeunes ouvriers parisiens
recherche dans le cinéma l'expression
d'une vérité sociale que représente
celui ci pour les étudiants danger que
nous avons rencontrés sous le kiosque à
musique un loisir comme les autres où
beaucoup plus qu'une simple 19,6
et comment choisissez-vous vos fils
alors on choisit le film le meilleur
film de la semaine passée hier par le
metteur en scène
puis alors quand on s'ennuie on peut
avoir n'importe quel film un western un
film comique et vous allez au cinéma en
bande tout seul avec vos parents peut
toujours en bandoulière enfin au moins
trois autres camarades ou alors des
vents de groupe pour voir un petit fils
me manque
est ce que le fait d'aller au cinéma en
bande augmente votre plaisir de voir un
film
oui après on veut avoir la peau et on
discute du film en allant boire et le
place au cinéma tu y at-il dans nos
loisirs eux pas une grande place à vrai
dire je m'intéresse au cinéma lorsqu'un
film a fait parler de lui bien alors ce
qu'il faut ça problèmes intéressants et
bien lorsque c'est un vieux classique
quoique tout le monde va voir à la
grande illusion les enfants du paradis
des choses comme ça il n'aime pas ça
assez importante et moins grandes que
celles de lecture du place énorme plus
que comme loisir comme passion et
quelques chants de films préférés vous
eux ce sont les films et psychologique
que je préfère justement à définir comme
un film à idées s'oubliera pas
psychologique ou move était là enfin qui
essaye d'apporter un sens à la vie
dollars de lui donner un sens oui vous
préférez les films comiques le film
dramatique
une dramatique pourquoi je crois qu'en
général la femme est mieux les films
dramatiques parce que elle est toujours
quelque peu émotive et puisse à lui créé
quelques sensations vous pleurez au
cinéma je dois dire que oui est ce que
vous êtes pour ou contre la censure
absolument content parce que je crois
que il n'ya pas d'art si on prend le
cinéma coma il n'ya pas d'art sans
liberté on n'a qu'à regarder en urss
la plupart des films qui nous sortent
c'est des films prêchi prêcha par deux
ou trois exceptions j'ai plus
les liaisons dangereuses et alors vous
pensez que c'était normal de le censurer
ce crime
penser que ce film ne pouvait nuire aux
jeunes je pense que oui quelle façon car
sa morale que dans jules et jim
je trouve que m c'est un film qui aurait
dû être beaucoup plus fortement censurés
parce que le problème du couple a trois
n'a jamais intéressé
puis je crois que je ne suis pas la
seule c'est à choquer retour à paris au
quartier latin comme leurs camarades
provinciaux les étudiants parisiens
interrogés au hasard sont tous contre la
censure
par contre si les jeunes filles danger
elle pencher vers un cinéma plutôt moral
cette étudiante parisienne
vous êtes tous vos contre la censure ont
radicalement contre contre toute sorte
de censure
alors oui à peu près très souvent les
films censurés sont des films excellents
et avant d'avoir 18 ans vous allez voir
les films censurés allonge déjà n'ai pu
entrer vous à ne jamais laisser entrer
non mais vous aviez envie d'aller les
voir en ville c est ce que vous pensez
que cela aurait modifié aurait une
influence néfaste sur vous ou
certainement pas surtout à l'heure
actuelle je crois que les jeunes eux
mêmes de 18 ans surtout au dessus de 18
ans pour tout à fait apte à voir les
films et dernier round
je considère le cinéma comme une arme
c'est à dire c'est un
c'est un moyen qui doit servir à faire
prendre conscience aux gens de certaines
choses et je suis contraint certains
cinémas commercialisés pensez vous que
le cinéma plus avoir une influence sur
votre façon de penser depuis je pense
qu'il s'en défende oui de quelle façon
vous avez remarqué
ah oui je la façon de soutenir d'agir
peut-être pas d'agir nommé soutenir de
penser même quelquefois les problèmes de
l'amour
peuvent varier en fonction d'un film que
j'ai vu comme jules et jim
des alizés mombasa sous un certain angle
et à la lumière de ce film de la
personnalité de truffaut et bien ça peut
différer mais vous même changé dans oui
je peux sentiment je peux certainement
évoluer dans mes sentiments en fonction
d'un film ou d'un giro prend une minute
m'enfin pas prêt après j - par réflexion
nous soit d'amour au cinéma le cinéma
étant donné que c'est un art moderne
il serait donc on enseigne le cinéma
comme on enseigne les lettres paraître
lundi vous accepteriez que vous causent
pas prolonger de 4 5 heures pour uriner
ma vie ce serait très intéressant
soyez satisfait on apprendra bientôt le
cinéma dans les lycées
nous ne pouvions terminer notre enquête
sur les jeunes et le cinéma sans nous
rendre rue des beaux-arts au minotaure
c'est dans cette librairie spécialisée
où s'entassent des milliers de l'insee
de brochure consacrée au septième art
que se rencontrent et se retrouve les
fans du cinéma comment sur les
cinéphiles à l'issue du sommet
ecoutons-le avec quel métier faites vos
jeux suite lors d'une hauteur est ce que
le cinéma peut avoir une influence sur
votre vie oh bien sûr oui quelles sortes
d'alliances mois pour moi le cinéma une
très grande importance on peut dire
qu'ils m'aident à vivre que pour moi
c'est une manière de vivre de voir le
monde c'est une façon tout à fait
nouvelle de voir deux mondes appréhender
les gens le cinéma qu'est ce que c'est
pour vous tous enfin c'est quelque chose
si tu me fasses une raison de vivre pour
moi c'est la vie dans le sens du nom
complet du mot quoi papa un mirage de la
vigne en reflet d'une retranscription
c'est la vie elle même c'est à dire
l'amour l'amitié la révolte
tous ces sentiments qui font l'homme
alors que la littérature la peinture la
musique semble réserver certaines
classes le cinéma grâce à son mode
d'expression original et à sa plus
grande facilité de compréhension est
devenu l'art de tous les jeunes sans
distinction de milieu et si une faible
partie de la jeunesse le considère
encore comme une distraction de hasard
il n'en demeure pas moins l'un des
phénomènes sociaux les plus
représentatives de notre époque
[Musique]